i got the new official xbox wireless
headset right here and i'm doing this
review to let you know whether or not
it's worth the 100
price tag and to give you a little hint
it's really good
xbox has been kind of leaning into the
sleek minimalist look with its hardware
while packing in some high-end specs and
that design philosophy
extends to the new wireless headset it
has impressive build quality high sound
quality some important features like
simultaneous bluetooth connectivity
dolby atmos and it was really
comfortable in my experience though that
does come with some conditions that
we'll get into later
but overall for 100 bucks this is
probably one of your best
options if xbox is your preferred
platform
there's so much more to get into though
so let's get into it
let's start by talking about the overall
build quality you get a sense of that as
soon as you take it out of the box and
hold it and you can see that it's very
flexible when you start to stretch
and contort it at least within reason
there's no audible creaking and it
certainly doesn't feel like it's going
to be cracking
it also helps that there isn't any fancy
design work on this headset it's just
plain black plastic subtle neon green
trim and the xbox logo on the right ear
cup
it's straightforward without many moving
parts or over-the-top branding
in terms of comfort the pseudo leather
and foam ear pads provided some
top-notch cushioning
for long sessions but as it is with any
leather-like
upholstery it will get sweaty after a
few hours but one thing to note is that
the headset
does clamp pretty tightly thankfully for
me
the pads provided more than enough
cushioning to kind of alleviate that
pressure but if you do have a bigger
head
then i do i like to think i have a
fairly normal sized head that is one
thing that you will
have to take into consideration another
thing that you should know is that for
these to fit properly on me
i had to extend the headband to its
maximum length
as you can see here you can adjust each
ear cup as you would do it any other
headset
and i have them extended to their max
length here and that's how i get them to
fit properly on me
so if you have a bigger head or if you
have very voluminous hair
you might have some issues getting these
on to fit properly
now let's talk about features it has
most of the essentials you'd want out of
a mid to high-end audio device
as with any wireless xbox designed
accessory this headset uses microsoft's
proprietary wireless tech that lets you
sync directly to a console without a
dongle or cable
just hold down the power button on the
headset and press the pairing button on
the xbox
and you're good this thing also rocks
bluetooth 4.2 and you can simultaneously
pair it to another device
in addition to your console for example
i was on discord
chatting and listening to a group of
friends through my phone
while gaming on my xbox series x the
leading audio technologies are also
available when using the xbox wireless
headset
both dolby atmos and dts headphone x can
be enabled in the console
settings although you do need separate
access to the respective applications
to utilize those features alternatively
you have windows sonic available for
free
which provides an improved audio
experience for the headset
now for features on the headset you have
volume control
relegated to the right ear cup it works
as a dial so if you want to
crank up the volume you just go like
that
and if you want to turn down the volume
you go like that
it's a pretty clever design i like it a
lot and if you want to adjust chat and
audio mix
it's on the left ear cup so there's kind
of a tactile feedback you get when it's
at
balanced perfectly at 50 50 but if you
want to turn in the turn up the in-game
volume a little bit more over chat you
just twist it like that and if you want
to hear chat a little bit more
you twist it the other way like that
it's pretty neat
another design choice that i like is the
microphone so it folds
in like that and then it extends outward
like that with a flexible rubber casing
that stays in place
and when you're using it it doesn't
extend that far
so it's not it's not in front of your
mouth so if you're eating or drinking
it doesn't get in the way as for battery
life i was impressed with how
it was able to hold up after a full
charge microsoft states that a 30 minute
charge should provide around four hours
of use and a three hour charge will
allow the headset to last about 15 hours
i charged it overnight and after using
it for about eight hours in a day
the xbox ui indicated that the battery
remained well above half
full now let's get into the most
important aspect of a headset
sound quality now i wouldn't claim to be
an audio file but good audio is very
important for the games that i play
having the proper sound stage and having
high quality music for some of the best
soundtracks that i love in games
so what i do is i run a sennheiser hd598
and i run it through a dac on my pc now
the xbox wireless headset
isn't necessarily going to stack up
against a 300 dollar setup
but if you are coming off of earbuds
that you're plugging into your
controller
or if you're using tv speakers or a
budget level headset
you are going to notice a significant
difference when jumping to the xbox
wireless headset
you'll hear a solid bass coming through
on default settings which is great for
games with bombastic moments
and impactful audio design music will
also sound bolder
and without the bass drowning out the
other frequencies even as you kick up
the volume there isn't much distortion
that comes through in the mids and highs
so the audio isn't abrasive
if you want it to get louder now at near
max volume you may notice that the audio
details get lost or muddled
and the highs can be a bit harsh but at
that point you should probably be
turning down the volume a bit
now i tested sound quality with games
like forza horizon 4
doom eternal and tetris effect connected
all of which feature emphatic audio
design
but in different styles overall
everything sounded great and had me
excited to turn up the volume on my
favorite games and tunes
now positional audio is very distinct so
competitive gamers should be satisfied
with the advantage they can get out of
the xbox wireless headset
audio cues were easy to pick up when
playing gears 5 multiplayer which
allowed me to better anticipate enemies
approaching from specific locations
directional sound makes the audio
experience in non-competitive games feel
more full as well
while playing ori and the will of the
wisps for example i noticed the
direction of ori's attacks
left and right was represented sonically
which was subtle
but effective it's also nice when the
whimsical soundtrack comes through with
great clarity at the same time
i had a similar experience in an older
game like lost odyssey
where the high quality audio gave a new
edge to the cutscenes and made nobuo
uematsu's incredible compositions shine
brighter
as for the microphone quality it's
functional your voice will come through
well enough for others to hear you
clearly but it's nothing to get excited
about if crystal clear communication is
key for you
you might want to look elsewhere for
example here's my voice using the
microphone on the xbox wireless headset
testing testing 123 xbox wireless
headset
microphone quality test so overall
i really like this headset it has high
quality sound it's super durable
and i just like the sleek minimalist
look of this thing and it was very
comfortable in my experience though that
is something that you're going to want
to look into a little bit more for
yourself
but to put it in simple terms if you're
willing to drop a hundred dollars on a
headset for your xbox
you can't go wrong with the new xbox
wireless headset now if you want more
details on my experience
head on over to gamespot.com and check
out the full written review
which is also linked in the description
box below thank you for watching
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you